You know when you like think of an idea and you're like,
Yeah, this sounds good in my head,
and then you come to do it and you're just like...
"What
The fuck
Was I thinking?"
Hey guys, so today
I am going to explain the plot of
Domestic Girlfriend
after I eat this, uh
This-this fucking ghost pepper...
(i regret my life decisions)
So, um,
We're gonna, we're gonna see how spicy the plot's gonna be.
*lipsmack*
After I take a bite so um, yeah,
Here we go.
This was-this was such a bad idea...
Alright.
Ohmygod
Ohmagod
MMMH!
*lipsmack*
Swallow!
AH
*lipsmack*
*cough*
Oh my god!
*lipsmack*
Ugh, oh my god.
So Domestic-
*lipsmack*
Domestic Girlfriend starts up with a guy, Natsuo,
*hiccup*
*lipsmack*
Okay...
There come the hiccups.
*hiccup*
*lipsmack*
Starts up with the guy Natsuo and he-
*hiccup*
He sleeps with a girl
*lipsmack*
*hiccup*
..called Rui
He sleeps with a girl called Rui!
Ah!
And-
*lipsmack*
He does that because he's trying to forget
*hiccup*
The person who he actually loves
*lipsmack*
Which is his teacher, his teacher called Hina!
Oh my...
Oh my...god!
*lipsmack*
Ah
And
Blegh!
*lipsmack*
So he's in love with his teacher and he sleeps with another random girl.
And his dad's getting remarried and he finds out that
The-
Ah.
*lipsmack*
The person who's he getting married to is the mother-
Oh my god, it keeps getting worse!
[ The Anime or the Pepper? ]
*orgasm*
*lipsmack*
*finishes orgasm*
The person he's getting married to is the mother of person he slept with and his teacher!
*when you bust a nut but she kept sucking*
And they're all going to start living together!
*audible pain*
That's cool!
And he's still in love with Hina!
And he finds out Hina is getting-having an affair with a married man!
Okay.
Just calm down.
ohmygod, it's not going away
He finds out Hina is having an affair with a married man-
and-
He tries to stop it, and-and... he's-he ends up tonguing her, and-
-and Hina slaps him.
And he was just like-
*dying*
And then she pushes him down anyway, and starts tonguing him
Oh ...oh my god, this is so hot[ ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) ]
This is so hot!
[Ikr? ͡(° ͜ʖ ͡° )]
I need a break.
And then-
-and then Hina starts-
...where was I?
And then Rui starts...
*Gigguk.exe has stopped working*
Rui finds out...about the affair-
and then-
they-
They try to stop Hina from having..-having the affair.
And then-
and then- (x2)
and then- (x3)
Rui fucking throws some water on the guy and then um-
*more orgasm*
And then-
It's just...everyone starts fucking liking each other.
And then Momo comes in.
She's had so much semen.
God, she's guzzled so much semen.
But she's such a sweetheart.
And then er-
-This-
I can't fucking think.
The suppository scene. Oh
su...
Natsuo has to put a suppository-
up Rui's butt-
I D O N ' T  K N O W  W H A T  T H A T ' S  G O T  T O  D O  W I T H  A N Y T H I N G ! ! !
It was cut In the anime mostly.
They didn't cut it in the manga!
Holy hell!
and then-
and then- (x2)
Natsuo confesses to Hina properly
and Hina is like,
"If you want to be with me you got to die, bro"(lmao)
"You gotta double suicide with me"
and-
Natsuo doesn't want to do that.
Then Rui's like,
hOlY HELL
Rui is like hey, "Ay bro, you wanna tongue?"
Natsuo is like, "Yeah sure. Why not? My other sister won't get with me!"
and so they start tonguing.
(Basically Kuzu no Honkai's plot)
and then after that's done,
Natsuo-
walks in-
on a really "touching" scene-
with Hina.
*gasp* homygod
By "touching"-
I mean she's touching herself!
She's got-
She's got Sticky Fingers!
(SUTIKKYI FINGÅZU)
Why am I making JoJo references?!?
(THERE'S ALWAYS TIME FOR A JOJO'S REFERENCE!)
and then
Suddenly, Natsuo and Rui start tonguing a bit more
And no one leaves-no one in this house leaves their door lo-locked!
Everyone leaves it open!
(Anime logic 101)
So Hina sees-
And-
And she's like-
She's like, "RUI! WHAT THE FUCK ARE YOU DOING!?!? HE'S YOUR BROTHER!!!"
And then, Rui's like:
"Its-It's not related by blood"!!
👏
(MEME REVIEW)
and it's like-
¯\_(ツ)_/¯
and I'm like,
👏👏👏👏👏👏
Good on you Rui! You know what you fucking want
Oh my god
and then uh-
And so it turns out all along
that Hina liked Natsuo all this time and she was just pretending-
and um, yeah, they start going out
and having ,uh
and having a proper relationship. She moves out they start fucking kissing.
They start fucking kissing in the hallway of of the school
and hoping no one will find out. It's the most awful secret relationship of all time.
I think that's everyone
I think that's everything that's happened in the anime
(Fuck this shit, I'm out)
(Got Milk appears)
Holy Jesus.
I never wanna do that again in my life.
Yeah just describe the plot after having a fucking ghost pepper, Garnt. Fucking great idea. Why why why?
Why did I never ,why did I not think of that before?!
If you enjoyed that if you enjoyed the Domestic Kanojo overview
Follow me on patreon- use my coupon code on bookwalker. Whatever the fuck you want. Just leave me with this milk. Alright
DON'T FORGET TO SUB AND SMASH THE LIKE BUTTON -Sim (and whoever else added captions)